الحرب الاوكرانيه تاخذ مسارات متشعبه فبعد
كارثه تفجير سدك خوفكا عرفت الساعات
الماضيه تفجيرا جديدا استهدف خطا انابيب
لنقل الامونيا يتعلق الامر بخط انابيب
يربط بين مدينتي الروسيه واوديسا
الاوكرانيه تفجير اتهمت
بتدبيره حيث قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
مجموعه تخريبيه اوكرانيه فجرت خطا انابيب
توليتي اوديسا خلال عمل ارهابي ادى الى
اصابه العديد من المدني وقالت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه دائما ان التفجير تم في
منطقه خاركيف التي استعادت جيش الاوكراني
السيطره عليها كليا في خريف عام 2022
مساء بتوقيت موسكو فجرت مجموعه استطلاع
الاوكرانيه خط انابيب بتولياتي للامونيا
بالقرب من منطقه خاركيف ونتيجه لهذا العمل
الارهابي وقعت اصابات في صفوف السكان
المدنيين
تم تزويدهم بالمساعده الطبيه اللازمه وفي
الوقت الحالي يتم تصريف بقايا الامونيا من
الاراضي الاوكرانيه عبر الاجزاء المتضرره
من خط الانابيب
المتحدثه باسم وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه
ماريا زخرفه قالت في بيان لها ان اصلاح
خطا انابيب الامونيا الذي تم تفجيره في
منطقه خارك في اوكرانيا سيستغرق من شهر
الى ثلاثه اشهر
وفقا للمعلومات المتاحه في الخامس من
يونيو تم تفجير خط انابيب الامونيا
في منطقه خاضعه لسيطره اوكرانيا نعم انها
نفس منشاه البنيه التحتيه المدنيه التي تم
ذكرها مرارا وتكرارا كجزء من اتفاق حبوب
البحر الاسود وبسبب استهدافها تم اخراج
احدى محطات الضخ من الخدمه وتشغيل صمامات
الاغلاق ومع ذلك تسربت المواد الخام وفقا
للتقييم الاولي ستستغرق اعمال السياره
والاصلاح لا يقرب من شهر الى ثلاثه اشهر
بعيدا عن خرق اذ تعيش منطقه خرسون حاله
استنفار قصوى على خلفيه تفجير سدك خوفكا
تبادل الاتهامات تواصل بين طرفي النزاع
حيث حملت كل جهه المسؤوليه للاخرى الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ادلى باول تعليق
بخصوص الكارثه حيث قال انكياف وبناء على
توجيهات من الغرب تواصل تصعيد الوضع
واستخدام الاساليب الارهابيه مضيفا ان
الهجوم على محطه كخوفكا مثال على ذلك اما
الرئيس الاوكراني فقد عرب عن خشيته من
حدوث اضرار بيئيه جسيمه لا سيما وان الاف
الحيوانات محاصره بسبب الفيضانات فيما وصف
رئيس مجلس الامن القومي والدفاع
الاوكرانيات الروسيه بتورط اوكرانيا في
تدمير السد بالامر
السخيف مؤكدا ان الجيش الاوكراني لم يكن
متواجدا في المنطقه وقت حادثه تدمير السد
الاتهامات باننا وراء تدمير السد امر
مستحيل فعليا في ذلك الوقت لم يكن جيشنا
ولا مواطننا متواجدين في المنطقه للاسف
الشديد تم احتلال منطقه منذ مايو الماضي
من قبل الروس لذا فان القول باننا فعلنا
ذلك في وجودهم هو امر سخيف
نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيه اهانه
ماليار قالت ان تفجير سد كخوفكا ادى الى
تدمير مواقع عسكريه روسيه في خيلصون
واضافه روسيا تسببت في اضرار كبيره
لقواتها بتفجيرها سد كخوفكا وحسب نائبه
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني فان السيل الناتج
عن تدمير السد ادى الى انجراف الالغام الى
مناطق القوات الروسيه في خرسون بعد تفجير
سد كخوفكح
على صيد الانساني يواصل الطرفان بذل
مجهودات لاجلاء المدنيين وبحسب رئيس
الاداره العسكريه الاوكرانيه لمنطقه خرسون
تم اجلاء 1700 شخص من مناطق الفيضانات
الخاضعه للسيطره الاوكرانيه وافادت
السلطات الاوكرانيه انها ستضطر لاجلاء
اكثر من 17 الف مدني من المناطق المتضرره
على الجانب الروسي اجلت السلطات حوالي
1300 شخص واعلنت حاله الطوارئ في الجزء
الذي تسيطر عليه من منطقه خرسون
[موسيقى]
معنا من كييف غيث احمد مناف عضو هيئه
الاعلام الحربيه الاوكرانيه سيد غيث اهلا
بك معنا في اخبار الساعه من العربيه بدايه
ما حجم الاضرار التي تم حصرها حتى الان من
تفجير سد كخوفكا وكذلك خط الامونيا
لكم ولكافه المشاهدين الكرام بالفعل لا
يمكنني انا ان اتحدث عن الحجم الماساوي
الذي الان يشهده مواطنون الاوكران داخل
المناطق الجنوبيه
بلغت ارتفاع مستوى المياه في منطقه خرسون
بالتحديد اكثر من ثلاثه ونصف مترا كما ان
ايضا يحاول الان فريق الاجلاء على مستوى
متطوعون ايضا مدنيون بعدد 1500 متطوع حتى
هذه اللحظه يحاول اجراء المدنيون من تلك
المناطق ومن تلك المدن التي خرجت بالفعل
من الخدمه مباشره هناك منازل
اختفت عن الوجود هناك منازل
غمرتها المياه بشكل كامل هناك ايضا ابنيه
وصلت ارتفاع المياه لاكثر من الدور الثالث
الوضع ماساويه لغايه الان تحدثت مجموعه من
منظمات المجتمع المدني عن اسفها وايضا
ادانه ما قام به الاحتلال الروسي حسب
وصفهم بانهم قاموا بتفجير تلك
السد وهو سد كهرومائي ثاني اكبر سد موجود
في اوروبا الشرقيه وهو سد نظرك الذي كان
يمد المدن بالمياه العذبه وايضا شبه جزيره
القرم كانت ايضا تستمد المياه من تلك
السد الموجود هناك وايضا عندما نذهب
ونشاهد حسب ما تحدث مجموعه من المحللون
العسكريون بعد ان قامت روسيا بتسريب
مجموعه من الفيديوهات التي يؤكد عمليه
الانفجار وكيف حدث هذا الانفجارين اغلب
المحللون الغرب وايضا الاوكران برهنوا بان
الانفجار كان من داخل محطه التوليد او
داخل المركز الاداره التابع لتلك اسد اي
الانفجار كان ناتجا عن استهداف مباشر من
قبل الغام تم وضعها مسبقا هناك ولكن غيث
حتى الان لا توجد تاكي دات غربيه بان
روسيا هي المسؤوله يعني بشكل صريح عن عن
هذا التفجير تفجير السد كذلك طبعا الجانب
الروسي ينفي الاتهامات بانه يقف وراء هذا
التفجير فهل الجانب الاوكراني لديه ادله
دامغه تدعم حجته بان روسيا هي التي تقف
وراء تفجير السد
نعم بكل تاكيد هذا ما صرح به الرئيس
الاوكراني عندما ادانا بشكل كامل وايضا
اتهم روسيا مباشره بهذا الانفجار حيث ذكر
بانه لديه الادله والبراهين بالاضافه الى
ذلك وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني
ارسل خطاب رسميا الى مجلس الامن
واعلن او طلب انعقاد جلسه طارئه لادانه
روسيا عن وصفه بالارهاق او جرائم الحرب
البشعه التي حدثت في اوكرانيا بالاضافه
الى ذلك برهنوا بان هناك مجموعه من الادله
التي تدين روسيا بتلك التذكيرات كما ان
الرئيس الاوكراني ذكر في هذا اللقاء
الاخير بانه قد حذر الغرب وحذر الامم
المتحده منذ عام كامل بان روسيا قامت
بتفخيخ تلك
او تلك السد الموجود في اقصى جنوبي
الاراضي الاوكرانيا ولكن ان دعيتني ان
اتحدث هناك تصعيد اخر خطين وهو
تصعيد مفاعل
ذا حيث انخفض مستوى المياه وهذا على طريق
ما تحدث به الهيئه الحاكمه العسكريه
لمنطقه زفروجا حيث اكدت بان هناك انخفاض
مستوى المياه في احدى
اعتقد تستخدم للتبريد تبريد محطه صحيح
بالفعل بالفعل اثني مترا انخفض مستوى مياه
الضغط التبريد التابع لمحطه وقد يؤجج هذا
الموقف الى انفجار كارثي نووي قد لا يحمد
عقباه من قبل الطرفين سواء كان الروسي او
الاوكرانيه من هو المسبب حتى هذه اللحظه
هذا الانفجار قد ربما يكون طرف ثالث او
ربما يكون احدى الطرفين الذين لهم من
قاموا باستهداف المباشر غيث احمد مناف عضو
هيئه الاعلام الحربيه الاوكرانيه من كيف
شكرا جزيلا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات